the city of Memphis has been frustrated
by potholes in its streets especially as
they pop up during the winter freezes
wet weather plus regular traffic make it
hard to keep up potholes make driving
less safe damaged vehicles on the road
and slow down traffic I'm max
Saltonstall and today we'll explore how
Memphis with some help from spring ml
and Google cloud came up with an
automated scalable system to help them
combat their pothole problem in one year
Memphis repaired over 63,000 potholes so
we're talking about a ton of work and a
huge effort required to locate them
throughout the city to help scale up and
improve efficiency the city could use
data they already have the city buses in
Memphis all have video cameras though
this rich source of data wasn't being
used as a source for detecting potholes
many cities already have an assortment
of connected devices and data being
collected
so there are problematic potholes in
Memphis and the need for a better way to
identify the miss scale if they could
collect video from the buses detect
potholes somehow integrate GPS data to
locate it in space and then integrate
with city information service systems
such as 3 1 1 to dispatch crews but how
are they gonna do it machine learning
the city of Memphis worked with spring
ml to develop a model with Google Cloud
sideo intelligence API that could check
the video footage each night and store
results in Google Cloud storage and
bigquery then they made a web UI for the
3-1-1 operators to view images and
evaluate the results deciding on
priority for dispatching the repair
crews take a look at what it can do
[Music]
the new system allowed the city teams to
take action quickly and address the
newly detected road issues within 48
hours
now Memphis has safer roads with fewer
potholes more efficient employees lower
insurance claims and a modern approach
to service delivery automated pothole
detection is just one example of cities
using their data to augment city
services and improve government
efficiency with the help of cloud
infrastructure and video intelligence
solutions thanks for joining me for more
information about spring ml and the
google cloud video intelligence API
check out the links below
[Music]